Kris Jenner receives an emergency phone  call from Kendall that startles everyone  every kid has versions every day  [Music]  do you want me to come to take you to  the hospital okay I'm gonna come and get  you where are you where are you I'll be  there in 15 minutes  what is going on I know oh my god mom  what's going on she doesn't feel well  she's not quite sure what it is in the  latest episode of Keeping Up with the  Kardashians Kris jumps into action to  support her daughter Kendall during a  panic attack  Kendall struggles from anxiety and I  think she has so much going on that she  gets herself really worked up everyone  says I'm fine but I don't feel fine with  the 22 year old models busy schedule  Kendall finds it hard to cope with her  condition when duty calls overseas and  during Fashion Week  Milan's coming up and trying to juggle  it all is overwhelming  [Music]